it's been a whole year since the finale
of the man in high castle be warned if
you continue on it might spoil your
enjoyment of all the charming things in
the first season like executions
assassination seppuku genocide oh and
those cute Hitler Youth last season left
us with a lot of questions first and
foremost who the hell is the man in the
high castle after season one you
probably assumed it was Hitler based on
him knowing about the alternate reality
shown in the films and being a man in a
high castle but according to the newest
trailers you are probably wrong the man
in high castle might actually be this
guy I believe you had my stapler now
he's got his tapes but he still can't
find his stapler nope is the freakin
Heisenberg device actually a time
machine the roll of film Wagner passed
to the Japanese science minister shows
nuclear fission between uranium-235 and
a neutron which is the mechanism used in
little boy the bomb dropped over
Hiroshima this would lead one to believe
that the heisenberg device is a bomb and
there will be a cold war between japan
and germany in season two now that both
empires possess nukes but the fact that
tapes showing an alternate reality
exists shows that there's an obvious
controlled transfer between realities on
this show this has led to the theory
that the Heisenberg device is actually a
power source strong enough to rip
through time or dimensions or something
or that it is actually a bomb but the
byproduct of the explosion it creates is
a dimensional rift interestingly enough
Nazis and our reality may have actually
tried to work on time machine it was
called die Glocke or the Nazi bell
you might remember it from zombie mode
and call of duty world at war and the
ridiculously reliable show ancient
aliens an extraterrestrial hybrid what
exactly are we looking at when we watch
the tapes whether it's time traveller
universe jumping the film's depict a
reality that is different from the one
depicted in most of the show the new
trailers show dated film cans on shelves
why are they numbered by year how do
they know what year it is in an
alternate reality unless they're getting
there by Time Machine are you telling me
you built a time
how does to go me meditate himself into
a different reality in the book to go me
purchases a necklace made by Frank Frank
on a whim after sensing its energy and
experiences this moment of
cross-dimensional travel why or how this
happens isn't covered in the text but
combined it with everything else going
on in the show and one can assume that
this is the start of some Hiro Nakamura
shhhhhh lastly I promise is kono michi
from an alternate reality to go meas
assistant koto Michi is from Nagasaki
and has what looked to be burn scars on
his right arm which led many of us to
believe that he is from a reality in
which nuclear weapons were used on Japan
while it could be a coincidence
like Hitler being a man who lives in a
high castle but not the only man who
lives in a high castle I think there's
more going on based on his reaction when
to go me mentions Nagasaki's beauty also
Kota Michi tells to go me he is a good
one perhaps too good for this world what
do you mean by that bro are you saying
you're from a different world
by the way I wouldn't even bring the
[ __ ] up except for the fact that too
good for this world is the name of a
song on the season 1 soundtrack boom
conspiracy or someone just has a lot of
confidence in their musical ability the
man in the high castle is just one of
the shows we love for more TV nerdiness
plus movies and comics stick with
GameSpot universe if you want to stay up
to date with all of our TV videos be
sure to subscribe to GameSpot universe
on YouTube it's GameSpot's permanent
home for TV movies and comics as of
January 3rd so if you subscribe you
won't miss a video
[Music]